BRETT MORGAN: Hello,
and welcome to
this week's Map Studio.
I'm Brett Morgan, one of the
developer relations engineers
working with the maps
team here in Sydney.
This week, I'd like to take you
on a tour of using Google
Maps with Dart.
What is Dart?
I hear you say.
Dart is a new programming
language from Google designed
to bring structured
programming to web
applications.
This includes things like
classes, libraries, package
management, and tooling.
Here you can see the most
visible tool in the Dart
project, the Dart editor,
available at dartlang.org.
This tool is based on
[INAUDIBLE] frame work, and is
also available cross platform.
To get started, let's create
a new application.
I'm going to call this
one MapsApp.
First thing I always do when
starting a new project is make
the darn thing actually runs.
So here we go, launching it up,
and making sure it reacts.
That looks good to me.
We have a working tool chain.
So the next step, and one of
the things I mentioned that
was great about Dart is
that it has packages.
In this case, I went to
pub.dartlang.org and found
that there was a package that
wraps the JavaScript Google
Maps API up in a nice and
Dart-friendly way.
So once I save this pubspec.yaml
file, you'll
actually see the packages
included in this application
will grow to include Google Maps
and all the things that
Google Maps depends on.
So now we can actually go ahead
and start writing a maps
application.
The first thing to do is put a
div on the screen, this one
here, that will include
the map.
The second thing is to make
sure that we include the
Google JavaScript
API for maps.
Next--
and this is something I keep
forgetting to do-- is to make
sure the map canvas actually
has a height.
What I'm doing here on both the
body and the map canvas is
making sure that we take
100% of the screen.
Next, let's write
some Dart code.
As I was mentioning
before, it has
tools, and it has packages.
So what we have here is the
first one, Dart HTML, gives us
the ability to reach into the
dom and use CSS selectives to
pull nodes out of the dom,
or elements in this case.
The next thing is the Google
Maps dot dart file.
It includes object wrappers for
things like map options.
So traditionally in JavaScript,
this map options
is a bare JavaScript object
with key value pairs.
In the Dart version, we actually
have typed setters
and getters for each of these
attributes of map options.
So we know that zoom
takes a number.
Map type ID takes a map type ID
object, so on and so forth.
And we wrap that all up,
throw it into a Google
map, and off we run.
And we have a working map.
Now, the next step is that I
like my maps to be on the
screen and be nicely visible,
but I'm not quite sure what
numbers to put in here
to pull out the
specific detail I want.
So what I'm going to do now is
I've added a pair of changed
list nodes to the map, one
for the zoom level
and one for the center.
So now what I'm going to do is
when I rerun the project, I
can turn around and center the
map where I want it, zoom in,
get the location in Sydney
that looks--
how about there?
Maybe a little bit further in.
That looks good to me.
OK, now I have some
magic numbers.
Now that I have these magic
numbers, printed so
beautifully in the console here
by Dart, we can put them
back in the source code and
rerun the application.
That looks a whole lot better.
Now I can actually see a chunk
of Sydney that I'm interested
in walking around.
If you're watching our Google
I/O announcements, either live
at the venue or online
afterwards, you'll know that
we released a new set
of map tiles.
How do we get to these
from Dart?
Well, this is the JavaScript
package that I was talking
about up here.
This allows us to reach into the
JavaScript context and set
true to this part of
the tree here.
And this will turn around and
allow for a new set of tiles
to be pulled in by the
Google Maps API.
As you can see, a much better
set of colors, and I think a
much more readable map.
The next step is--
of course, with any map-- is
to put a whole bunch of red
dots on it.
So I have a data.json file
I prepared earlier.
This data file is care of the
places API, which you can look
up on Google Maps.
And what we have here is a set
of lat longs and a bunch of
restaurant names.
So what I want to do now is
to put this on the map.
First thing is first, let's
head into the Dart.
And you can probably guess
what comes next.
We're including a package that
allows us to turn JSON objects
into native Dart objects.
The next thing we're going to
do is we're going to write a
function that works at Dart
structure and pulls out what
we're interested in, ie, the
lat long and the name.
So what's happening here?
We're making a request back
to the server to get the
data.json file, this one here.
And then, once that is
successfully retrieved, we run
this inline function--
it's a nice inline anonymous
function, for those of you
keeping score at home--
to actually parse the data, walk
through, and then create
a set of markers to
put on the map.
Now, the most important step
when creating something like
this is to actually
go look at it.
So there we go.
Hopefully I've lined everything
up correctly and
will now have the map.
Look at that, a map
with red markers.
So I can zoom in here a bit,
hover over things.
And we'll see titles of pizza
places around Sydney.
What have I shown you here?
I've shown you how to easily
use Google Maps from Dart.
Just a handful of lines of code
has us visualizing JSON
data on a map.
Please reach out to
me on Google + if
you have any questions.
Thank you.